>>> TIME NOW FOR THE RIDICULIST.
A GIANT EFFORT TO NORMALIZE
RELATIONS WITH CUBA.
PEOPLE OF CUBA GOT A 6'4" DOSE
OF REDHEAD AMERICAN AWESOMENESS
WHERE THE BEST EVER LIVED, CONAN
IN CUBA AIRED THE OTHER NIGHT
AND IT WAS SPECTACULAR.
DRANK RUM, MADE FRIENDS.
NO ONE KNEW WHO HE WAS.
MY FAVORITE PART WHEN HE HAVANA
ROOFTOP, THE PERFECT VANTAGE
POINT FOR LIFE IN THE ISLAND
NATION.
>> THE GUY YELLING, INSANE.
I THINK HE'S YELLING AT THE DOG.
OH, GOOD, THE DOG IS BARKING
AGAIN.
GOT SUSPICIOUSLY QUIET.
>> AS THE SUN SET OVER HAVANA, A
ROOFTOP EPIPHANY.
>> NOW REPORTING ON THE BARKING
OF THE DOG.
AND REALIZING ANDERSON COOPER
HAS A VERY EASY JOB.
>> FAIR ENOUGH.
I DON'T GET TO TEST THAT FACT
BUT A FEW THINGS THAT YOU'RE
DOING WRONG.
JUST SOME MINOR TWEAKS.
LET'S GET THIS ONE OUT OF THE
WAY.
IF YOU WANT TO DO FIELD
REPORTING, YOU HAVE TO REEL IN
THAT BOUFFANT.
THERE'S A REASON MY HAIR IS
SHORT.
IT DOES NOT GET BLOWN AROUND BY
AIR STRIKES OR I GUESS IN THIS
CASE DOG BREATH.
YOU CANNOT REPORT WITH YOUR HAIR
BLOWING AROUND LIKE THAT.
IT'S DISTRACTING FOR THE VIEWER.
THE CAMERA GUY CAN'T EVEN KEEP
IT IN FRAME ALL THE TIME.
AND ALSO, JUST A SUGGESTION, IF
YOU'RE GOING TO REPORT IT FROM
THE SCENE, YOU'VE GOT TO KEEP IT
INTERESTING.
WHERE'S THE BELLS, THE WHISTLES,
THE PASSION, THE BREAKING NEWS
BANNERS?
>> THE DOG HAS STOPPED BARKING
NOW.
WE WAIT NOW TO SEE IF THE DOG
WILL CONTINUE BARKING.
THIS IS WHAT THEY DO ON CNN.
THEY PRETEND SOMETHING IS
HAPPENING FROM A DISTANCE.
THE DOG HAS BEEN FED, POSSIBLY
THE DOG HAS GONE TO SLEEP.
ALTHOUGH THAT WOULD BE UNUSUAL
FOR THE DOG TO GO TO SLEEP THAT
QUICKLY AFTER BARKING THAT MUCH.
THE DOG IS BACK NOW.
[ LAUGHTER ]
ON THIS GORGEOUS NIGHT.
WE DON'T KNOW WHAT KIND OF DOG
IT IS.
IT SOUNDS LIKE A SMALLER DOG.
EVENTUALLY MAY GROW INTO A
LARGER DOG.
PRETTY MUCH HAVE PROVEN HERE I
CAN FILL SIX HOURS A NIGHT ON
CNN.
>> I STAND CORRECTED.
THAT IS HANDS DOWN HAIR-UP